an act of war those are the words of
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is
speaking about what he called Iran's
attack on a Saudi oil facility president
Trump is ordering new sanctions on Iran
as his top diplomat secretary Pompeo
continues to meet throughout the region
correspondent benjamin hall reports
tonight from our middle east newsroom
the pressure on Iran is mounting
today Saudi Arabia laid out evidence
they say proved Iran was behind the
attacks displaying cruise missiles and
drones they claimed were you shortly
afterwards Secretary Pompeo flew to
Jeddah to discuss the next steps with
the crown prince while US investigators
collected evidence on the ground at the
attack sites he accused Iran of acts of
terrorism and war and risking the global
energy supply
to war of this nature there's always
risk that could happen in the US
president Trump has also ramped up the
pressure saying he had instructed the
Treasury to substantially increase
sanctions on Iran and warning of further
action there's the ultimate option and
their options are a lot less than that
Saudi Arabia's defense minister said 18
drones and seven cruise missiles were
fired from the north though they were
still working to discover the exact
launch point and he called on allies to
back them against the threat Iran's
continued aggression the sponsorship of
terrorist group and interference in
maritime commerce represent a common
threat to us all the Iranians continue
to deny involvement saying the Yemeni
Houthi rebels were defending themselves
and they don't want war but adding they
would retaliate to any attack a
dishonest Saudi Arabia the Emirates
America certain European countries in
the Zionist regime which started the war
in this region Saudi Arabia says 50
percent of the oil production cut by the
attack has now been restored calming the
markets and easing fears that emergency
reserves need to be used but few believe
the threat has gone the fact that Iran
was able to bypass billions of dollars
of Saudi Arabian air defenses and strike
seemingly at ease at the largest oil
facility in the world well that is now
the grave concern and certainly Saudi
Arabia in the US will be discussing ways
of bolstering those defenses but other
ways in which Saudi and the US can
respond will they remain to be seen